[Music]
foreign
Floyd director of global manufacturing
Industries at Google Cloud it's my
pleasure to welcome you to the third
episode of the smart Factory
Transformers
in this new video series from Google
Cloud we tell the exciting stories of
how manufacturers are in the midst of a
transformation Journey digitizing
production processes and Reinventing
customer experience using data and AI
in this episode we will talk about
remote field equipment management and
how manufacturing data engine can be
used for scenarios outside the factory
to facilitate Digital Services for
customers of manufacturers
what we can see immediately on this
screen is a really nice visualization of
where the equipment currently sits
geographically focused in in this
particular case in North America
we have
2945 assets currently being monitored
around about 286 of those currently
under warranty and there are 244 alerts
and other key kpis that we need for the
business which you can see on screen
now importantly when it it comes to the
uh opportunity for additional business
we can see just below that there are
actually asset upgrade opportunities
according to the warranty expiration
date
and this is the combination of two
different sorts of data this is taking
other the disorder information the sales
information and then combining it with
the operational status of the equipment
so we can combine both of them to say
now is a good opportunity to do an
upgrade for the customer based on the
utilization of the equipment itself and
also worked on the expiry date for their
warranty so we've got very good kind of
sales lead information that's coming
through in this particular
dashboard that you see and we also see a
number of critical alerts coming through
on this same dashboard that provides us
with an opportunity to provide more
service directly to the customer and
provide our own organization with
additional insights
so what we're going to do is take one of
these assets right from the top here
that is showing it abnormal engine speed
and we're going to dig into this one to
find out what's going on and come up
with the right type of solution for this
customer
so first of all Let's uh open this one
okay so what we have on hand here
backup power generator that you can see
on the left hand side and on the right
hand side we've got instantaneous
information that's being provided to us
one we can see the asset location which
we take actually from the purchase order
and we look at the delivery location so
where it's being actually delivered the
alternative to that is where we get
signal information such as GPS
what we do here is just get the general
location which we need for when we would
want to schedule service or for when we
would want to be in contact with perhaps
a local dealer or evaluated reseller
so for just for fun in our fictitious
manufacturing company we've had them
sell a power generator actually back to
Google cloud and so here is a
visualization of one of our data centers
and we know that the equipment is
operating somewhere on this location and
using Google Maps that you can see here
it does give us the opportunity not only
to understand more about the overall
environment but then does allow us to do
some additional things such as calculate
the distance to the local dealer that I
spoke about or perhaps work out how much
time there will be to deliver from a
warehouse uh directly to this site if we
were doing spare parts or wishing to
send someone on site for service
so having a little integration as simple
as that can actually be very insightful
for When We're working directly with a
customer
now what else we see uh up on screen
here is that there are some really nice
kpis some good performance indicators
that we can see that help us understand
the overall status of this equipment
with the customer
a couple of things are critical that we
can see or one that is critical and
others which are approaching the first
one being that 40 days remaining until
the battery is recommended to be
replaced we can see some things here
which are very good so coolant level is
still looking very good but we've had a
few failures to start which on a backup
generator is really not a situation that
we want
now continuing along we can also see an
overall aggregate of the equipment
Health there is a asset score which we
calculate on the Fly which would be at
100 when it's delivered to the customer
currently is at 60 so therefore not
exactly where we would want it to be by
specification and we can also see some
of the indicators as to why so the
alternator health is in the yellow zone
so it's not looking particularly good I
would say and the engine Health overall
has been severely impacted now our task
is to try and work out why so we've got
somewhere to begin but now we need to
look for some more specificity
so continuing on what do we see at a
glance well the first thing that we can
see there just looking at the overall
properties of this generator
that according to the runtime that we
can see there by Cycles so how many
times we've had a start and a stop
sequence that at around about the 80
Cycles we had a fairly significant drop
in voltage and the role of this
generator is voltage and current and so
this is what it needs to do and it's
simply not performing its task we can
also see that the load hasn't increased
and so there wasn't as if we we suddenly
overloaded the generator that's causing
this particular situation the root cause
of this is yet to be known we have to
continue to drill down
so let's see if we notice anything else
one of them that we check always
vibration and in any type of mechanical
equipment excessive amount of vibration
can lead to to breakdowns mechanical
breakdown so we do see a fluctuation
there at a glance in the equipment which
could be a leading indicator of other
underlying problems in this particular
generator
so let's dig into this generator and we
have the asset ID we've got all the
information firmware number and so on we
have from the equipment itself so we've
got an idea of what this particular
piece of equipment is
now we're going to dig into some of the
sensor information and see if this is
going to help us understand what's
currently going on
so we do see a couple of interesting
things here one is that there was a
slight increase in pressure but over
specification and the same the engine
has tried to increase speed at the same
time which is perhaps not something that
we were really looking for so the
machine is trying to compensate for
particular circumstance just to keep its
performance where it needs to be but
despite its best efforts we can see that
the efficiency is actually all over the
map and so we're not getting anywhere
close to where we would want to be um
obviously we would want to be much
higher level efficiency and much more
consistent
now another interesting
noticed immediately is that fuel
consumption has literally gone through
the roof which is something that we
would not want to see ordinarily and so
there must be some leading indicators as
to why and continuing on
we can see even more dire circumstances
that the voltage has also dropped fairly
significantly I would say that this
generator is is now approaching a
critical situation
now to know more about exactly how
critical it is we perform a core
calculation using machine learning and
artificial intelligence to create a
score for remaining useful life now this
is a approach that many many types of uh
manufacturers use around the world for
different types of equipment to
calculate a threshold of inefficiency
this is where the equipment is no longer
efficient but it may continue to run but
it's just running very poorly I would
say this equipment has crossed that
threshold and we can see there that that
actually the amount of Cycles remaining
we would normally want to see many more
is actually getting very low so we're
going to go below 60 Cycles remaining
we've already crossed that and it looks
like that the the predicted going
forward does not look good when we get
Beyond 40 Cycles so therefore we know
that this piece of equipment needs to be
maintained almost immediately
now why what is going on that would be
causing this well we see something quite
interesting first of all that there is
high coolant temperature we see that
there is uh intake manifold temperature
that is high it's generating a code on
the diagnostic computer we're getting an
instant understanding of what the
outcome of that code was so it was a
shutdown in one case it was a warning
all of this information is available to
us instantaneously and at a glance but
because we're storing it in
manufacturing data engine it does
provide us with digital twin
capabilities so that we can understand
specifically what needs to be done for
this customer and for this particular
asset and if we look over here on the
right hand side there are some
recommended actions which will take care
of part of the condition one is we
should replace air filter within the
next 15 days the battery we already
worked at was critical at 40 days and so
it needs to be replaced and we're saying
we should schedule maintenance in order
to take care of these bigger items which
cannot be performed directly by the
customer themselves and so therefore we
will put a schedule together
and uh that concludes my demonstration
for today and I certainly hope that you
found good value in this particular
approach to using an underlying data
engine in order to manage assets at
large whether it be for understanding
the maintenance exposure for the
customer or whether it's understanding
things so
many thanks for spending time with me
and I certainly hope that you found this
episode interesting and informative have
a great day wherever you are in the
world and many thanks again
[Music]
thank you